several years ago I became familiar with
this name Dave Rubin Ruben what is what
is Dave Rubin doing keep hearing a buzz
about him and uh this is when you
started your locals format and I said
okay what is locals oh it's this great
Free Speech platform that this comedian
named Dave Rubin has founded I think I
want to join this so I signed up I paid
my little bit of money and I loved the
platform and as someone who was really
concerned about the censorship that was
happening in various parts of the media
on YouTube hearing about people being
Shadow banned Etc I really appreciated
was it what Dave was doing in creating a
platform first free speech and then the
next thing you know
Dave
actually responded to one of the
messages that I sent him to say Dave I'd
love for you to come to Budapest you
know just this disembodied you know
person sending him a message and he was
very kind enough to respond and refer me
to his his uh PA at that time who now is
I think in Nashville
and she was kind enough to work with me
and we got Dave to participate in our
canceling Council culture program that
was held during the height of the covid
and unfortunately we were still in
lockdown so many of the presenters like
Dave participated via zoom and this is
like the greatest thing ever and he was
so kind to do this and then you know
it's like what is Dave doing now well
this thing called Rumble was out there
and it had been out there but Rumble
wanted to get bigger and Rumble wanted
to take on YouTube and they approached
Dave and they wanted to do a deal with
Dave so now locals is a part of Rumble
and to show you what a true
in it in it for the fight Dave is he
didn't just cash out and take his money
from Rumble he exchanged his stock for a
share in Rumble they got that right good
and so he is in it he's he is really
just this great wonderful person who has
taken on this issue of censorship and
um and take it on in a really personal
way
and I just think it's the most
fascinating story that here is this
comedian who is doing more than any
politician that I know of to help
protect Free Speech which is the first
amendment in the U.S as we know and so
without further Ado may I please
introduce the Dave Rubin
thank you thank you guys and thank you
for the kind words uh now that you're
all familiar with my stock portfolio we
can begin I don't give any stock tips uh
I hope you don't mind the handheld mic
instead of the podium people always want
me to run for something and I feel like
if I get to a Podium this will not end
well so we're going to do the handheld
mic
um I have to say I'm quite moved you
know uh we're just coming back uh from
nine days in Israel we flew in this
morning and uh so I'm quite accustomed
after six days in Jerusalem to all of
this Stone which really uh it's history
it's history and when we were putting
this trip together and we we got the
call uh to come to Budapest come to
Hungary and and do some things in Israel
we thought there really is something
that we can we can try to find that
we're all searching for right now and I
and I think some good things are
happening in Israel there's clearly some
good things happening in Hungary there's
some good things happening in America
okay but we're we're missing something
that I think is beginning to be uh kind
of unfurled here and maybe in Israel as
well that I wanted to talk about today
before uh I get into any of that I want
to promise you guys that this will be a
uh a one-of-a-kind speech because I I
try as you know as many of you probably
know uh I toured with Jordan Peterson
for about a year and a half uh 2018 and
2019 about 120 shows 20 countries and he
never gave the same lecture twice so I I
always try to do that Jordan Peterson
will actually be here in Budapest
tomorrow night I'm sure some of you are
going to be there and uh and I think the
idea is that Jordan has put forth in the
world are are the things that are going
to correct so much of what is wrong with
all of our cultural institutions our
political institutions our technological
institutions and all of those things so
uh first I thought I would just tell you
a little bit about my my political
adventure for some of you that maybe not
are not so familiar with me and it's
funny because I I just sat down with a
bunch of Hungarian media for about an
hour beforehand and I was trying to
figure out what am I going to talk about
tonight sort of where where am I at
mentally and having come off this trip
especially being in Israel where
you know it's interesting they're
they're doing they're doing history and
future they're trying to balance these
two things and I think that really is
what almost all Western societies are
trying to do right now it was very clear
I hadn't been to to Israel in about
seven years they're building up very
fast meaning the country's just going up
roads and buildings and skyscrapers
everywhere new cities absolutely
remarkable they're making they're making
the Desert Bloom it's green everywhere
it's just incredible in a place with
very few natural resources but they're
also digging down they're Excavating and
they're uncovering the history of of
their people and really of Western
civilization and that was sort of what
our thesis was when we were trying to
figure out how we were going to do this
trip what are what are we looking for in
Israel and Hungary as I said that that
is happening uh that that is right that
is right because there is so much uh
that is not right so before I get to all
of that a little bit on my on my
personal history uh because you know we
throw around these words classical
liberal conservative all of these terms
and and people sort of don't know what
these things mean anymore we I think
we're going through a massive reshift uh
of virtually everything politically
there's new alliances to be had uh you
know we're 20 some odd years into social
media and all the algorithmic tricks
that are silencing us and Shadow Banning
us and boosting some people and
de-boosting other people and all of
these things and we're trying to figure
out how do we how do we kind of get
through this so very briefly uh in terms
of my own my own sort of political
Evolution I was a lefty most of my life
I was uh I grew up in New York Democrat
family we were we were liberals now
liberalism of course at least from an
American perspective wasn't always what
liberalism is now there there were sort
of there was a moderate Force within
liberalism uh John F Kennedy Jr was a
liberal ask not what your country can do
for you ask what you can do for your
country that was an idea that was a
Democrat principle for he was anti-war
he was low tax he wanted to reduce taxes
these were Democrat principles and that
was sort of the Democrat tradition that
I kind of grew up in and then of course
in the last 15 years or so probably more
so in the last 10 years decade or so
something happened to the Liberals the
Liberals sort of all went crazy left
they all became this thing that we now
call Progressive which in essence as I'm
here in Eastern Europe is far more in
common with Communism or Socialism or
any of the other horrific collectivist
movements of the past than anything that
had to do with any sort of American
value or anything related to Freedom or
individual liberty or anything like that
but it really caught on and it caught on
in a really crazy way and I think it
basically sideswiped everybody where
suddenly all of our cultural
institutions our political institutions
are mainstream media a big Tech
everything sort of started pushing this
crazy what we all now refer to as wokism
it started pushing this on us that your
identity the if you happen to be born
white or you're born black or you're gay
or you're Chinese or whatever it is your
immutable characteristics somehow or
more important than the individual
that's inside you and we all know or I
shouldn't say we all know any any
somewhat evolved person knows that this
is simply not the truth I could look
around this room and if you think that I
could attain anything by looking at any
one of you and thinking well there's
someone he's a guy he's middle-aged he's
white he must think this I mean that
really is the essence of prejudice right
what is what is Prejudice Prejudice is
to prejudge and yet we've somehow done
something now where our entire
our entire sort of running ethos and
from an American perspective is based on
the things that are completely counter
to individual liberty which is what the
country was set up on and this sort of
just rampaged through absolutely
everything and it led to a situation
where a guy like me who was a lefty I
started waking up to some of this stuff
and saying hey you know something
something's not right here guys what's
going on all I started to do and this
was sort of the the moment
all I started to do was talk to some
people on the right and I talked to guys
that I'm sure many of you are familiar
with like Larry Elder and Ben Shapiro
and Dennis Prager and Glenn Beck and
what I found was I had some political
disagreements with them but I found them
to be thoughtful and they knew what they
thought and why they thought it but more
than anything I found them to be sort of
generous of spirit there was there was a
kindness there and an ability to agree
to disagree and that I thought was a
liberal tradition
unfortunately it no longer is so right
now in America we have this really wild
balance uh well we had a balance and now
we have a disbalance we have an
unbalance I would say which is that one
party has gone completely off the deep
end and that's scaring an awful lot of
people and clearly America which is the
it's the leader of the world for a lot
of good reasons right we created this
country in 250 years we bought more
peace and uh and acceptance and decency
and opportunity and the pursuit of Happy
happiness to more people in the world
than could have ever been imagined it is
the greatest human experiment ever and
yet we right now have a movement in
America that is completely counter to
that and it is fueled by big Tech it is
fueled by the Democrat Party and the
media establishment and all of those
things and now it seems to be being
exported right it seems to be being
exported so that I'm here in Hungary
talking about this because you have a
version of this and I was in Israel
yesterday talking about this because
they have a version of this and the
question is well how did it how did it
burst forth how did this happen so that
suddenly we are now questioning things
that we know we don't have to question
anymore my friend Douglas Murray who I'm
sure many of you are familiar with the
great conservative author you know he
constantly talks about how we had all of
these problems solved basic problems
were solved and now we've decided to
unearth all of these things that
basically Now The Barbarians are at the
gate and we're debating what gender
pronouns they are this is a problem
right this is a real problem instead of
dealing with the issues head on we're
suddenly wondering are there biological
differences between boys and girls and
should this uh be discussed privately
with with teachers and students hiding
that from parents I mean these are crazy
issues we all know they're crazy and I
think one of the reasons we we sort of
lose constantly I always say on the show
we're just constantly sucked to this
slow descent to hell with these people
is because those of you that are here
that are broadly conservative and and my
first book was a full defensive
Classical liberalism and it's kind of
funny I can't it's hard for me to from
an American perspective to to say that
I'm a liberal anymore and it probably is
for some of you guys as well because the
word liberal has been so hijacked and we
could do a whole different talk on that
but for anyone here that's broadly
conservative right now and what I mean
by that is you basically believe in
reality you believe in biology you want
limited government you believe that you
have some autonomy over your life the
reason we keep losing the reason we keep
being sucked into that that seemingly
bottomless pit
is because we have jobs we have families
we have other things to do
and the other guys don't they really
don't they've put everything into you've
met some of the protesters they don't
have jobs they don't have good hair
stylists either and they could wouldn't
kill them to hit the gym but
but there really is something to that
there is a set of people right now in
all of these Western countries that are
that are hell-bent on on demolishing the
goodness of the West and we have to
figure out a way around it and it has
hit everything uh as some of you guys
know I I lived in California for the
last eight years and a year and a half
ago post covid and and post lockdowns
and mandates and injections and riots
and all of the craziness crime and
defunding the police and everything else
I couldn't take it anymore and I moved
to the free state of Florida
and I I talk about Florida a lot on the
show because one of the things that's
happening in Florida I think is
something that probably that seems to be
happening here where I think Hungary
seems to be sort of Blueprinting for
Europe how how other European nations
can go ahead and exist and defend your
borders defend your culture as you see
fit it's your right to do that it's not
another nation's right to do that you
guys as hungarians will figure out how
to go forward and how to live freely and
all of those things but that's very
counter obviously to a to a much bigger
globalist operation right and in America
we beautifully have a federalist system
we have this idea that you can bounce
around from state to state if you don't
like it in America you're not happy in
Cali well you don't have to leave
America you don't have to go to
California or you don't have to go to
Mexico or Canada right you can actually
just go across this country you can go
to Florida and live almost a completely
different life and I can tell you having
lived in California with the crime and
the drugs and all of the stuff I moved
to Florida where there's low taxes
there's low regulation there's a respect
for individual rights and autonomy we're
removing the woke stuff out of the
schools all of all of the things that I
sense that you guys really want here and
which were most of the questions that I
got from the Hungarian media before
joining you tonight
um it's happening in America and now
what's happening is Florida is now
Blueprinting that and sending it across
the nation so school choice for example
instead of just funding systems that are
endlessly failing we're now funding
students in Florida and then you can
take that credit and you can go to a
public school or a private school or a
charter school or home school whatever
it might be but you as the parent have
some autonomy in that so that your
children will not be brainwashed that's
now happening in Iowa is happening in
South Dakota in a bunch of other states
and it's not just on the woke stuff
we're getting ESG out of our
governmental institutions we're doing
all of the things right we're funding
the police when we get illegals that are
brought into Florida
we we send well we send them to Martha's
Vineyard and then we very quickly we
very quickly find out how tolerant the
Liberals are do you guys know that
Barack Obama has a 30-acre estate on the
water in Martha's Vineyard on the water
which makes you wonder if he believes
any of this climate change nonsense
that's one thing right but 30 Acres
there were about 30 illegals that Ron
DeSantis sent to Martha's Vineyard Obama
could have given each of them an acre
right each of them an acre and instead
they got rid of them what like in 24
hours it was really it was really just
remarkable which is consistent with what
we see out of almost everything with
with the left these days they have very
easy solutions to very complex problems
and usually if you just pull that really
thin veneer back there's not much there
there's a lot of outrage there's a lot
of Hysteria there's a lot of anger but
there aren't really good ideas and
that's why so much is so broken in
America right now and it's again why I
wanted to do this trip because I wanted
to see what was right
in Israel what's going right in Hungary
so that I can help bring it back to
America because we actually need help
right now I mean that's becoming very
obvious to me you know our our the
Multicultural nature of America which
again is is remarkably incredible the
idea that people from all walks of life
from every corner on Earth could come to
the same place and because they believed
that they have some
purpose the pursuit of happiness that
they could pursue happiness that they
could build a great nation is really
incredible but 250 years into this thing
we're we're lost we really are now we
have pockets where it's working
obviously Florida is one of them but as
a nation we are somewhat lost and what I
was Finding in Israel is that there
there still seems to be a purpose there
you know they just celebrated their 75th
anniversary and there seemed to be a
real purpose the people did not forget
why they created the nation in the first
place they have all sorts of external
problems they have internal problems
with this judicial Reform Bill but when
you walk around there you walk around
Jerusalem and you see people first off
the people of every color and Creed and
all of those things all of the diversity
that really doesn't matter that much
because of course intellectual diversity
is what actually matters but you see all
these people they're still trying to
build something and something has
happened in America where we don't know
what we're trying to build anymore and
that's why it feels like it's crumbling
I would say fairly really quickly and
unfortunately now because of because of
tech and because of of a media that that
is exacerbating the situation uh the
question is will we be the world leader
and I suspect if I polled all of you
guys right now you probably still do
want America to be the world leader to
some extent but right now and I say this
is an American this is on foreign soil
which is a hard thing to say I don't
know that you should trust us that much
right now right like I don't know that
we're doing it correctly enough with
enough moral Authority
enough uh fortitude
to really lead the world right now and
if we don't do it it's going to be much
worse I think most people recognize that
so having talked about Florida a little
bit uh when I sat down with the uh with
the journalists before before coming up
here uh everybody was asking me about
this this Trump DeSantis thing so I want
to just address that quickly I want to
try to bump around to a couple of things
uh because I've only got about 30 or 40
minutes here uh it's interesting because
you know Trump was an excellent
president from from my position I I
didn't vote for him the first time
around I did vote for him the second
time around I've interviewed him I'm
friends with his children you know they
all live in Florida his whole family
lives in Florida I think our economy was
great the world was sort of lined up
correctly things were really working
under Trump and had kovid not happened
uh I think we'd be in a very different
situation right now I think we'd be in a
successful second term for him the left
would still be going nuts we'd still
have riots and all those things but the
sort of general focus of the country
would be right America would be leading
again we would be doing things properly
almost if you basically took virtually
everything that we're doing now and you
just reversed it that's where we'd be
and things would be better
um so everyone keeps asking well well
Dave you know where do you stand on this
Trump this had this thing because that's
really where this thing seems to be
heading and as much as I uh supported
Trump the first time around I sense we
really need a shift right now like we
need we need a shock to the system the
way that the way that Trump was a shock
to the system the first time around and
no one thought it could happen and all
of the excitement of Twitter and the
trolling and all those things it really
was it was the thing that nobody thought
could happen and it did happen
I'm sensing we need that again but a
slightly different version of it what
I'm sensing
right now is that we need a shock to the
system of Competency we need a shock to
the system of someone getting up there
and doing exactly what they say they're
going to do and doing it right and
lining up an agenda and basically like
dominoes knocking those things down and
that really is what Ron DeSantis is
doing in Florida and I think people all
over the world I mean I'm getting emails
literally every day from hungry and
plenty of other countries from Japan
people are like can this really happen
can we actually figure out a way to have
a competent clear leader and so that we
can get back to those simple founding
documents and we can have a country that
is sane again and not have to do this
Mass migration that we're doing across
the United States because on one hand it
really is nice as I said Federalism is
really great you can pick up and go
right if you guys aren't happy here in
Budapest you can move you can move to
the suburbs and it'll perhaps be a
little more conservative or something
like that but you really would have to
leave the country if it really started
changing we don't have to do that and
and that's that's a beautiful thing if
we can if we can fix the federal system
and I think there is a chance to do it
and I also think and I can sort of read
it when I when I talk to people about it
wouldn't it be nice if things just kind
of got normal again you know wouldn't it
be like wouldn't that be something you
can applaud normalcy yeah
people don't even remember what normalcy
is right I mean these last couple years
between covid between all of the big
Tech censorship between the media lying
to us about everything and I think you
guys have a version of that as well you
know the media has lied about every big
story everything if you just took
everything the media did and you
reversed all of it if you read if you
picked up the New York Times
we were at the airport we were at the
hotel this morning here in Hungary and I
saw the New York Times and it's very
rare that I see a print newspaper
anymore and I looked at the headlines
and I was like man this is just
propaganda but CNN is doing it and the
New York Times are doing it and the
Washington Post is doing it and then
when you look at big Tech where big Tech
is then censoring stories for them right
the hunter Biden laptop which we now
know it was all true and a whole bunch
of us thought it or we a whole bunch of
us thought that the Russia collusion
thing with Trump was a lie but we
couldn't really say it because they'd
Shadow ban you or or delete you all
together or a whole bunch of us thought
that it might be a Wuhan lab leak or
that mandates were coming as they were
telling us they weren't coming all of
these things they lied about every
single big story so I think what we're
what we're all kind of struggling with
right now
and again this is why I wanted to take
this trip to figure out what it is we
can take from the old world because
there were good things in the old world
great thinkers of the old world
incredible people who built unbelievable
cities I mean what an unbelievable City
you have here absolutely gorgeous that
you guys are now rebuilding right I mean
it's incredible
we have to take some things from the old
world and we have to bring them into the
new world we have to figure out what is
this new world going to be
and I think linking that to the sort of
political situation we need a leader at
this point and I don't think all the
answers are political I really don't I
think that you know as as Andrew
Breitbart said politics is Downstream
from culture so you have to fix the
culture first and then maybe you can fix
the politics you can't just magically
find someone who politically is going to
do it right and then just fix all of
your problems that's not really the way
it works if you can fix a few things I
think for I think in almost every
situation it's it's a bottom-up approach
if you can fix a few things in your life
first whatever that means to to link it
back to Jordan Peterson if you can stand
up straight with your shoulders back if
you can clean your room do a few things
in your own life right and conservatives
are pretty good at this sort of thing
right conservatives generally have jobs
and wear clothes that fit it's sort of a
thing
if you can do a little bit of that and
then you can start fixing some of the
culture because when they come to you
and they say actually we're going to
teach your seven-year-old in second
grade who's a boy that they're actually
a girl and you actually have the
fortitude to say no you're not or I'm
going to remove my student from this
school or you're going to fight it by
showing up to a a board meeting
or whatever it might be then you can
start resetting things one of the videos
that I did for prageru and I'm sure many
of you guys are familiar with prakeru I
think the third video I did it was
called The Bravery deficit because we
seem to just be afraid of everything all
the time we're afraid if we say anything
that's out of line anything that's
Politically Incorrect we're going to be
canceled we're afraid we're going to
lose our job we're afraid and Anonymous
amorphous Twitter mob is gonna come and
say mean things to us and it's kind of
all true right like it's not just that's
not made up you might and I have no
doubt if I pulled every single one of
you everyone in this room and perhaps
perhaps myself included we're not always
saying everything we know to be true
right because there are consequences for
that but the more we do that
we just acquiesce we just give grounds
for the people who would gladly control
us and silence us to do that and we've
given them an awful lot of air and I
think what's happening now uh finally is
enough people are just like no
no more of this nonsense we cannot do
this anymore we do we don't want to
repeat the same mistakes that led to you
guys now having to rebuild buildings
from World War II right we don't want to
end up in that place and yet we seem
very close to it so
I've tried uh in terms of interviewing
people I've tried to interview people
from across the political Spectrum to
kind of come up with the right answers
on this stuff it's interesting because
we were in DC Washington DC uh about a
month ago we took three days in DC and
we emailed everybody
in town Congress was in session they
were just coming back so we knew that
every every politician was going to be
there so we emailed about 18 Republicans
and literally everybody said Yes except
then Mitch McConnell actually he fell so
he couldn't do it and then in a bizarre
twist uh Rand Paul senator from Kentucky
libertarian Center one of his staffers
was stabbed because it's DC so then he
couldn't come which was sort of sort of
fitting to the overall situation in D.C
and then Marcia Blackburn who's a
senator from uh from Tennessee she
couldn't come because there was a
shooting back home but I only mentioned
this because it shows you just all the
all the weirdness that is happening in
America right now but the point is we
got 16 Republicans I didn't tell them
any of the questions beforehand
interviewed them went great we asked
about 20 Democrats you know how many
Democrats we got
zero and that's not the white power sign
that's a zero
we got zero uh not only do we get zero
the only one we got one response it was
Rashida Talib who I probably think is
the worst of the worst at least her
office responded no everybody else just
ignored us uh but I mentioned that
because the only way we're going to get
through any of this the only way we're
going to figure out how to rebuild the
institutions how to get better
politicians how to communicate these
ideas better how to build new tech so
that we're not silenced into Oblivion
and all these things we got to figure
out a way to to rescue the same people
on the other side and they are there
guys I have no doubt that within your
own families we all have this right now
it's getting harder and harder to talk
about politics right and it's partly
because politics has become religion
especially for the left politics has
become the most sort of all-encompassing
thing that dictates their daily life and
then you wonder why why they're so
hysterical all the time because they
wake up every morning and there's
another outrage there's another cause
there's something else they now want to
believe the science they want to believe
in covid the same people the same people
who you know five years ago
were telling us all you know my body my
choice right that's what they were
saying my body my choice when it came to
abortion and women's rights and
reproductive health and that sort of
thing they were the most hysterical when
it came to forcing you to inject things
in your body
and part of the reason that they won't
talk right now and I wonder and maybe we
can find this out in the panel I wonder
if for you guys if it's as bad here as
it is in America part of the reason they
won't talk right now is because the
ideas just aren't that great but they
own so much of the cultural and
political and media landscape that they
can keep winning they can keep winning
without having to debate so when I was
doing these uh these interviews
beforehand just an hour ago or so uh all
all of the interviewers there asked me
the same thing why is it that
Republicans keep losing right like if if
we're so sure that you know we're
basically we've got the right ideas and
you know it's it's fairly obvious
probably to everyone in this room that
you know we have a better sense of what
humans want and what allows for human
Freedom well why do Republicans keep
losing I mean why don't more people wake
up
and I think there's there's plenty of
reasons for that a lot of it's sort of
Insider baseball politics
um but but part of it
I think is a massive branding problem
and it's a branding problem that led us
to losing all the institutions in the
first place
you guys have families that you care
about you have jobs that you care about
it's not your cause to be out there
trying to change the world you're trying
to change it in kind of a Marginal Way
in your own life and that's really the
way it's supposed to be but they they
went all the way to the end they went to
the end and they said we will we will
basically try to own the world
and that's what we have to fight against
and we're watching this all over the
world right now so on the on the tech
front
you know what's been so good like we get
these little moments guys right we get
these little moments where we get some
goodness one of the major good points in
the last year is that Elon Musk bought
Twitter
and we found out that a bunch of the
stuff that we kind of thought was true
were we being Shadow banned were we
being silenced was the government was
the United States government
which is supposed to abide by the First
Amendment the government cannot stifle
your free speech
the government was working with a giant
Corporation to silence people and again
whether that's the hunter Biden laptop
whether that's the the covid mandates
Etc but this stuff was happening now
it's kind of funny in some regards it's
like we then have these hearings on
these things and nobody ever gets fired
nobody pays the price and the Machine
just kind of keeps moving and I think we
have to recognize that you can sort of
get little wins here and there I heard
Tucker Carlson say that once you can get
little wins here and there but you
probably can't move the entire machine
so we can expose stuff and we can wake
people up
but you're probably not just going to
re-engineer the entire system you
probably aren't and then in a case of uh
Tucker Carlson and a few of you have
asked me about Tucker today uh you know
sometimes you can scare the machine
enough that you're out of a job which is
uh I suppose a little scary but I think
there's some ways that he can get back
in the game that'll be quite effective I
think Rumble might be one one option for
him
but we so we're fighting everything
right we're fighting a media that lies
to us we're fighting Tech that is
operating against us we're fighting
political people that that want to be
more political than us
right like I just know it I just know
you guys don't wake up every day even
all of you that are here because you
care about politics you don't wake up
really like thinking about politics as
the first most important thing and you
shouldn't and you shouldn't
so I'm trying to figure out how we can
how we can balance all of these things
how we can get back to some of these
good conversations I think we can do it
uh I think that as I said I think
DeSantis really is the guy that can get
us out of the mess imagine if we all
just woke up and we had good leaders
again right if we just had good leaders
again I think we could we can fix this
in probably about two years I really do
so that's what I'm here in Hungary for
and that's what I'm looking forward to
chatting with everyone up at this panel
about and uh I think that was roughly my
time for this portion and we'll we'll
sit and chat with everybody what do you
think
about about all of this stuff
all right
first of all many thanks indeed uh Dave
for that it was uh I agreed with almost
all of it so it's hard for me to know
what question to ask normally I'm fueled
by disagreement but I would say that
since you have been here not not as long
as you obviously you will stay in total
but since you have been here a few days
what are the two or three things that
you've noticed about Hungary and not
just Hungary but other parts of Europe
too which you think the Americans should
really take seriously as importing those
ideas yeah so actually I've only been in
Hungary for for just a few hours we
actually got in late this morning but I
can tell you having chatted with uh well
a couple of you guys and having chatted
uh with some of the members of the media
it seems fairly obvious to me that you
guys are addressing the actual issues
that are the problem which is why almost
everyone that I chatted with the media
asked me about the same sort of five or
six things that I tried to dive into
albeit somewhat briefly up here
um you know I think I think fighting
this woke thing really something about
the trans thing which I didn't really
talk about that much
um there's something about this thing
now really going for the children that
seems
intentionally designed you know my own
personal belief is that if you as an
adult wish to live however you want you
want to dress like a woman and you're a
man you want to dress like a man and
you're a woman you want to be in this or
that relationship you know once you're
an adult you can do whatever you want
that's my own personal belief I know
that's not everybody's belief
um and I tend to come more on a
Libertarian perspective on that
um but when they go for the children and
that really is one of the things that
put DeSantis on the map you know this we
know this was happening and it sounds
like it's happening in some of your
schools as well there were teachers that
were literally talking to Children about
sexuality and gender identity that we're
doing this privately without the parents
uh knowledge and they were doing it for
months on end often referring to a child
by a different name and all of these
things and that it's so it's so
incredibly outrageous it's hard for
people to really comprehend how twisted
it is and it was school policy and and
it was school policy and and Not only
was it school policy but it was the it
was the secrecy that was the really
twisted part of it you know what I mean
you you could potentially have a
situation where a kid I mean I find it
hard to believe that a kid at say eight
years old would be having these issues
but you could have an issue where
there's a kid who's a young teenager
that would be having some of these
issues and there could be some role for
the school to play potentially but the
fact that so much of it was done
secretly and really and and why I always
say that most of these things you have
to you need this bottom-up approach you
know one of the big wins we got
politically in America in the last three
years or so was that the election in
Virginia Which Glenn young and won he
went right in on this every politician
in America that has fought the culture
wars really said I'm going to fight this
so in this case he said I'm going to get
the woke stuff out of the schools he
then won and became governor in Virginia
uh obviously Ron DeSantis is sort of the
main one from the Florida perspective
but this is happening now with Christy
gnome in South Dakota and couple others
as well when you fight it people then
start getting a little bit braver and
that's really what we need more but
they're going after the children because
they're trying you know I say on show
all the time they're trying to break
everybody's brains and once they break
your child's brain and they can bring
that into your home and then as I
mentioned earlier you know now we're
fighting about politics all the time all
the time actually that was one uh and
then I'll move on uh that was one really
interesting lesson that I learned from
being in Israel for last week you know
Israelis they they fight and argue about
everything right it's it's a very it's a
very political Society because of the
security issues and all that but a few
people told me that for the first time
ever there it's coming into the home in
a way that is that is now becoming more
destructive and I think that's
intentionally designed by whatever's
whatever's really driving the woke
whatever this this globalist monster is
whatever whatever we want to call that
thing I think it is intentionally
designed right now to bring it into the
home and and until we can get it out of
the home and until that's why they're
going after kids it will just keep
coming and replicating I'm just going to
say there's a side issue of some
importance
um the right of parents to control their
children's education is specifically
protected quite high up in the in in
Universal Declaration of Human Rights
1948 I think it's something like article
12.
um I have until the last couple of years
I have never heard anyone on the left
specifically attack
that right
um even when reminded where it is
enshrined
um I haven't until recently heard
anywhere on the left attack for example
the right of free speech or the First
Amendment but now people on the left
actually argue this very
straightforwardly clearly and without
um disguise indeed not only people on
the left because of course
um at the moment there are institutions
of the U.S government engaged in
combating disinformation which are
themselves they are themselves making
statements criticizing
um free speech and and to some degree
democracy that's what I find most
remarkable do you want to cut well it's
interesting because uh you know in
California right now they are trying to
make California a sanctuary state for
underage children so this is children
who are under 18 who want to go through
gender transition me meaning that if
your parents let's say you're a 13 year
old boy now you identify as a girl
they've already crushed most of the the
requirements you know it used to be
you'd have to have several letters from
psychologists you have to be in therapy
for a certain amount of years all of
those things uh they've already
eliminated most of those requirements
but now if the parent let's so let's say
you're in Florida where they have now
banned by the way it's a past law uh
just through this Congressional session
that just closed last week it is a past
law they are now Banning gender
reassignment surgery and by the way you
should never call it gender affirming
surgery that's constantly what they do
and we always use their language and
it's a really bad mistake right it is
not affirming
I I would argue it's probably the least
affirming thing that you could do if you
were trying to affirm someone's gender
uh to actually chop their genitals off
but California California is now
actually going out of their way to say
we will be a sanctuary state for these
children so it it really this is
dystopian I mean this is 1984 level
stuff where they they want to take your
children from you and once they do that
then they got you and last thing on this
that's why they were pushing the the
vaccines on children so hard they knew
if you can get people who don't really
understand what we're being injected
with or why we why we are being injected
in them but I have to do it because I
don't want to lose my job or whatever it
might be it's one thing if you do it to
yourself right if you inject yourself or
your spouse with this stuff but once you
do it to your children and then you find
out it really didn't work and now
myocarditis and all of the other issues
that are popping up they've really got
you and and people really need to
understand that that's happening yes you
know you bring up the the question of
States sees using children it's not just
California Michigan does it Minnesota
does it the state of Maine is debating
it now I think Oregon and Washington
either they are going to do it or
they've already done it in the state of
Colorado people in this part of the
world who came through communism they
see what's going on this was how the
Communists saw the relationship between
the state and children the state took uh
took precedence over parents and that's
one of the reasons I love living here
I've lived here in Hungary for most of
the last two years I expect to spend the
rest of my life here
for all the flaws that this country has
it's not Paradise there's no such thing
as Paradise at least it feels real it
feels like people have it going crazy
here I I noticed that when American
friends come over I tell them that's the
first thing you need to know about this
country it's normal and the second thing
you need to know is everything you've
learned about Hungary from the American
Media is a lie almost everything and it
really is true and when people spend any
time here they've come to realize oh
yeah that's that's it we brought Tucker
Carlson over here summer of 2021 and
thank God for him because he spent a
week here broadcasting he went and
talked to hungarians actual hungarians
about the lives they they lead and he
flipped the narrative in America so I'm
so happy that finally now it's not at
the level of the senior Republican
leadership but at the Grassroots the
fact that you're here to see what's
going on here it's really important well
it's getting there it's getting there I
mean first off without going too far
down the rabbit hole of what happened to
Tucker I mean you know Tucker's out of a
job at the moment it might partly be
related to that he was starting to show
people there is a model for a society
that is good and decent but when you
when you talk about reality that that
also is why I think that the the
DeSantis thing really has teeth this
time because as opposed to let's say
Trump's first go-around where he got rid
of his opponents fairly quickly with
with some name-calling I I really
fundamentally believe this people just
want something sane that's all they want
no one 10 years ago you would have said
any of this gender stuff or the
neo-racism stuff or or that economics
would be upside down that you can just
endlessly print money that there should
be no borders all all of this this is
all stuff that 10 years ago virtually
every Democrat would have said this is
absolutely crazy and yet it is all
mainstream right now so it's a beautiful
thing I mean it's exactly why I wanted
to come here to to be around a play
people and a place that are saying hey
we have borders we have a nation state
um we don't want to go the route that
Germany has gone we don't want to go the
route that France is gone and it seems
to me that you guys are doing it
properly and you have some of the
intellectual backing to do it and now
you have the political backing to do it
and I can also tell you that you know
America we don't talk about Hungary a
lot I mean I guess Orban is the fascist
that's the main thing we know they say
that's all they say but you know what
that was a joke everybody that was a
joke
Victor Orban realized 12 years ago what
Ron DeSantis is just starting to realize
that the old liberal model of of
politics and Society is broken you know
how it was with that when we were
younger we were brought up to believe
that politics is here the private sector
is here and everybody stays it works in
their own sphere we all work together
somehow I went to journalism School
graduated in 89 and we were still taught
back then that the thing to do is to try
to be fair that's so over Orban
understood that the way power is really
used in post-liberal society when the
left has captured all of the private
institutions the only thing left to
conservatives is politics electoral
politics and we can't be afraid to use
the power we have to stop them you know
it's interesting so I'm sure many of you
know about the fight that DeSantis got
in with Disney after the the again quote
unquote don't say gay bill which had
nothing to do with being gay and the
word gay wasn't even in the title Etc
but suddenly a lot of conservatives Mike
Pence and Chris Christie and uh now uh
Nikki Haley a bunch of conservatives
came out and said oh no he's wielding
government power in a way that it should
not be wielded because we're I thought
we were the party of small government
and it was a real flip on on reality
because what DeSantis did with this he
was take away special rights so if you
believe in capitalism you believe that
every corporation every company every
business every individual should be
treated the same under the law and then
they they're going to fail and succeed
on their own Merit DeSantis took away
special rights they had special taxation
rights they had special rights to water
and an airport and a whole bunch of
things that even if you just cared about
amusement parks that we have Sea World
there and Universal Studios and Gator
world uh there's a lot of gators in
Florida they didn't have those rights so
all he did was make them equal with all
of the the competition that they had and
suddenly you had all these conservatives
going oh boy this is uh this is a real
misuse of power and that goes to exactly
what you're saying we're not unless
you're a complete Anarchist you believe
that a government should exist so if you
believe that a government should exist
what's the one thing it should do it
should be making sure that the playing
field is equal for everybody that's
exactly what he did it sounds like it's
what's going on here it should make sure
that business stays in its Lane when I
was a kid growing up business did not
involve itself in pushing radical social
agendas and uh being what we call woke
capitalists now that changed in the last
decade or two and the only way we have
to fight back is through the government
through elected power in the government
Orban gets it and this is one of the
reasons he went against George Soros so
strongly and in our country uh Ron
DeSantis gets it in a way I don't think
Donald Trump does because Donald Trump
for all of his virtues did not have the
focus and the policy discipline to
actually follow through
well I think one issue that Trump has so
so I agree with your assessment there
and again I think that's it that's also
just a function of in some extent
DeSantis being from Gen X I'm I'm 46
years old I think DeSantis is 45 I'm
fairly certain he's younger than me if
I'm not mistaken someone could Google it
to check but he grew up in a world that
was a little bit before the internet but
he grew up and and became a man and
became an adult in the world that we
live in now Trump and Biden and Pelosi
and the rest of these people they're
they're defending a world that doesn't
really exist anymore uh to really show
you a good example of that one one of my
Arguments for DeSantis has been that we
we need the mainstream media to die we
we really do and you know DeSantis one
of the things that he's done right now
he's not talking to NBC News anymore he
is refusing as a policy to talk to NBC
News and the reason he's doing it was
because there was a series in over a
couple weeks they were they lied about
like 10 different things in a row the
highlight of them being that Andrea
Mitchell who's one of the the premier
correspondents on on MSNBC uh she was
interviewing Kamala Harris
and you know we had this other issue the
other one besides the don't say gay
issue in Florida was that DeSantis was
getting woke stuff out of schools when
it came to to race as well so there was
a black an African-American AP studies
course that they were pushing on kids in
high school that also was going to have
woke gender Theory involved in Black
African-American studies I mean it's so
bananas you can't even make sense of it
but so he banned that that one course he
banned one course and then Andrea
Mitchell is on NBC News interviewing the
vice president about it and she said the
question I think I can almost get it
verbatim she said to Kamal Harris what
is it that that Ron DeSantis doesn't
want Americans to know about slavery
and it's like it's such a an absolutely
enormous lie and desantis's team said no
more we will not play this game now to
get to your point on Trump trump will
still play the game and that's part of
the problem I've been trying to explain
to people that that Trump in a way he is
part of the system now and he's feeding
the system and that's that's unfortunate
in a way again as somebody that I
genuinely I like him as a man but he's
he's now part of the system he's giving
it more energy we need to I the only way
you beat this Beast is to starve this
beast and I think that that's what
DeSantis will do it'll help us it'll
actually help an independent media rise
and it and it will let the the archaic
media uh just kind of Fall Away
just to get back a bit to the part where
you were talking about separating public
and private and both of you mentioned
this how this was a Cornerstone of our
civilization and I think that's true and
I think it was only the judeo-christian
civilization which had this
uh and where I want to go from here is
that I think this is on purpose so they
want to destroy this because actually I
don't think they want to live in a kind
of an orvilleian a society which we talk
about a lot I think it's much more
Sinister I think they want to live in A
Brave New World
uh and I think all the you know going
after the kids are kind of uh you know
the drug addiction problem the porn
problem is all about kind of lulling
people into this uh place where they
don't really realize that they are
living under Authority and dictatorship
so I just was interested how do you see
that do you think this is really
happening uh and also kind of what can
we do against this uh how do we kind of
get after these issues because I think
it's not just schools for example the
psychologists are full of this so if
let's say a 12 year old kid will go with
depression to a psychologist they will
also say to their kid that you might
have kind of you know some transfer
gender issue going on you're not
depressed you must be in the wrong body
so it's not just schools it's everywhere
basically look we have to understand we
are in a technological Revolution and
we're in the adolescence of that it's
funny I don't have my phone I usually
have my phone I mean like you guys all
the time I handed it to my assistant
right before we started but every one of
you have an iPhone in your pocket and
you have access to more information than
anyone could have ever possibly imagined
in the history of humanity but it's a
tool it's sort of like fire right like
fire is great it can warm up your house
and cook your food but fire can also
burn you and burn down that house we
haven't figured out how to behave with
these things yet and then the algorithm
sort of went crazy now there's chat gbt
and open Ai and we're finding out that
that has incredible political bias and
and the way that it's rewiring our
brains you know for anyone here that's
over probably 35 you might remember
remember the beginning of the internet
when you would go to a website right
you'd go to espn.com and they had 20
stories and you'd scroll down to the
bottom and then it was done right you
were at the end of the internet it was
amazing it was over the road was there
you were that was it but then uh what
was it about 15 years ago I forget the
guy's name that he invented infinite
scroll and now we have infinite scroll
use on every app on every web page you
go to it never stops so now now try to
hand that to a kid we all know what it
does to us as adults infinite scroll you
can go on Twitter and you see a
terrorist attack and then you see a
picture of a baby and then Joe Biden
said something stupid and then and then
you know what it's like what is that
doing to us what you know we are just
bouncing around between hyper crazy
emotions on top of the fact that it's
actually manipulated information in ways
that we don't understand as as Elon
talked about you know not only did the
government uh have access to Twitter but
he also had activists at the company
writing code so he still doesn't know
how to unfurl all of that that when I
when I met with him a few months ago
that was my main takeaway it's like it's
not just that he had to buy this thing
and correct it he has a he has a ship
that is that is completely rotted on the
inside and he's not even sure if that
ship uh needs to be replaced altogether
rather than just fixed but the point is
all of these things are manipulating Us
in crazy ways and yes in a in a sense
why why is there this push
to get us all on the metaverse why would
you want to follow Mark Zuckerberg and
Facebook into you know basically into
Ready Player one if any of you saw the
the movie or read the book why would you
want to follow him there did did you
know did these things hand us
but let's put it this way how many of us
are more social because of social media
right I mean I would say I would say
virtually nobody we're more angst
written we're more uh we're more
neurotic and all of those things so I
think figuring out a way to to behave
but it's personal right I'm not for
passing a law that you can't use your
phone a certain amount of time or any of
that kind of stuff and I think it should
be up to the parents regarding the
children but yes we have handed 12 year
olds the world the some totality of the
knowledge of human history and and let
it be manipulated and then handed it to
them say go into your room figure it out
and then we wonder why everybody's crazy
Posey Parker the activists in England
who uh anti-trans feminist
she was on a podcast with Louise Perry
the other day and she said that she
believes the trans phenomenon is just
the tip of the iceberg that it is the
first step towards the war for reality
that uh when AI comes in and
transhumanism comes in and all that we
are going to have to fight a tremendous
battle just to see to keep our our heads
in what is real and I think what is
human because I think the AI stuff and
all the you know robotic things coming
in is is really looking at bodies human
and I think that's really frightening
because in the end what is the question
to it I don't want you know Robots
coming on saying we're human and we have
a soul we're already talking about AI
having a soul which is just very
frightening to me well it's interesting
because every sci-fi movie that we've
ever seen whether you watch the movie AI
or Total Recall or the Matrix or
whatever sci-fi movie you liked as a kid
it's all coming to be right now right it
really is all coming to be right now we
are the bat what was the purpose of the
movie The Matrix the humans were the
batteries for the digital world in
essence that's really what the movie was
summed uh if you just whittled it down
that's what it was about and we are
basically giving ourselves to this thing
we may not be able to stop it uh and yes
I do think that the trans the trans
thing seems to be and again that's why
they're going for the kids we're all
going to age out right I'm not that old
but we're all going to age out but if
you can now break the reality of a whole
generation of kids who are five to
twelve and they will have no idea of
what history was or what is real or
literally that their body parts
connotate something to their reality uh
you're gonna have major problems and I I
do think that is a huge problem you know
one other thing on that because it came
up a couple times today you know I think
one thing that could possibly be done a
little bit with this is that you know we
have this this thing this LGBT community
and the t is the most anti-lgb thing on
earth it is the most anti-gay movement
that you could possibly have it really
is it
because in essence what the what the
trans Community is saying is there's
they're finding a five-year-old boy who
happens to maybe be a little bit
effeminate and he likes Star Wars and
Transformers more than he likes Barbie
let's say and they're saying you're
actually not a boy you're a girl and now
we're gonna put you on hormones and all
these procedures and maybe maybe and
hopefully he would grow up if if not for
this to be a somewhat functional by the
way he might grow up to be a straight
guy too because there are effeminate
straight guys and they're you know all
that's the Gestalt of life
um but the same thing would go for a
girl you might find a girl who's a
little bit more of a tomboy and they
would now say Oh no you're actually a
boy so they they are coming for
absolutely everything but I would say to
the you know that that the gay community
and I hate the phrase Community should
be fighting this probably on on the
Forefront of this because it's it's them
first and by the way it's the feminists
too I mean it's the women that should be
yeah when you watch a guy you know crush
a woman in wrestling and then you
applaud as a feminist you may have to
reevaluate the situation you know you
were talking about how new barriers are
breaking down in this new environment
and how new alliances are forming Barry
Weiss and I uh talked about this same
thing a couple of years ago she said
before the great awokening she said if
you would have ever said I would be on
the same side as Rod Dreer about
anything I never would have believed it
but here we are because we're both
fighting the same therapeutic
totalitarianism this is one of the
things I learned from talking to
interviewing people who stayed behind
and resisted communism in Central Europe
they said that whenever you find allies
people who are courageous you you have
to stand with them no matter what you
disagree on this one woman Camilla
Benderman Prague she and her husband
were the only political conservatives
and religious people in the at the top
level of the check resistance she said
Rod you mustn't imagine that other
Christians had courage they didn't they
kept their heads down like like
everybody else did my husband and I saw
these hip
and the others they they didn't agree
with us on a lot of things but they had
courage to stand up to totalitarianism
and we knew they would be with us when
the secret police came and they knew
they could count on us I think that
courage of people like Brett Weinstein
Heather highing Peter burgosian and
others that is the the glue that can
keep us together whether we're on the
left or the right yeah well look there's
there's something that does Bridge the
political divide and that's truth right
I mean that that would probably be the
great thing that that drives that so
some of those names you mentioned the
these are lefties these are good friends
of mine I mean Brett Barry uh Peter I
know Peter Peter I'm pretty sure he's
going to move to Hungary any day now I
mean he has seen he has seen the
promised land as he has told me many
times
um and he's an atheist still which I
think he's probably he'll get out of
that soon enough too but you know uh
he's he's on he's on the road let's say
but he believes in Freedom he believes
in in many of the things we've discussed
here but you have to find those people
you know since Jordan since I mentioned
Jordan earlier and he's coming here
tomorrow when we were on tour one line
he would change the speech all the time
but he had a couple lines that would uh
occasionally repeat he would ask the
crowd how many of you would think you
would have been Nazis in 1933 Germany
now nobody raises their hand right no
yes I would have been a Nazi no nobody
raises their hand and then he would
always respond the same way that means
you probably would have been a Nazi
because these things don't just
magically appear they appear by our
acquiescence as I said earlier they
appear because we are not brave and we
also don't have many models to be brave
and I also think it's partly that was
the real uh Twisted message of uh of
cancel culture and it's something that
Trump really got right you know when
Trump always says they're not coming
after me they're coming after you I'm
just standing in the way he really is
right about that Tucker they're not when
they were always going to get rid of
Tucker's advertisers it's not really
that they fear Tucker that much it's
that they figure he's a signal boost to
everybody else to go oh I can say some
things that aren't just the mainstream
claptrap of the day and we just need
more and more people to be brave but but
that that really is the first challenge
here and one advice would give people
who want to be brave because I think
you're very good example I mean you've
been a progressive you left Young Turks
started your own YouTube channel so
let's say to Taka now he's he's fired uh
what can he do because I think it's
really important but then you mentioned
this that if we're not brave enough they
will just trample us let me just say
something briefly about bravery because
people say this to me all the time and I
and I understand like I say what I think
for a living sometimes I think it's just
kind of naivete or stupidity or
something but when I was in Israel last
week the amount of people coming up to
me and saying Dave you're so brave and
I'm going you literally were in Gaza
like you you have lived through things
that I can all that I would never want
to imagine so you know bravery I would
say is a little bit on a on a spectrum
but but in a in a functioning free
Society unfortunately I suppose it is
brave to some extent I would say no this
like I can't give it to you in a in a
Pollyanna Pollyanna sort of way bad
things will happen you will say what you
think and you know what your wife or
husband might be really pissed at you
your kids might turn on you you you
might be in trouble at work all sorts of
things actually when I when I first uh
was leaving the left so to speak and
suddenly I was getting all this hate
from the people that I thought were the
the purported tolerant ones and diverse
ones and all that and I was every day I
would wake up and my email would be
blowing up hard like the worst
unimaginable things in Twitter and all
that
actually developed an autoimmune disease
in the middle of that I developed
alopecia ariata which I'm sure some of
you know of it's when you lose huge
chunks of your hair some people lose
literally all there and I was just
waking up with chunks of my hair just
falling out every day I was probably I'd
probably lost like almost half of uh of
the hair on my head it's all it's all
back now because I changed my stress
habits and things like that but I
mentioned that because you will go
through some bad pardon my French
it is just the reality of it there is no
way to sit here and say to you with a
straight face yes go out there and say
what you think about the world and it's
just gonna be great like it will not but
what is the option and I guess that's
the part that I don't have in me anymore
I don't know what the option is I have
to do it and I and I think it's probably
the most important thing you can do as a
human
to talk about your conversation with
Peter Krakow on exactly that point yeah
yeah John's talking about us when I was
first here the summer of 2021 I was a a
fellow at the Daniel Benson toot and I
asked them can you introduce me to
someone from the anti-orbond opposition
I just want to get a feel for why they
oppose oppose him so I was taken to meet
this guy Peter Krakow who was a liberal
and outspoken anti-orbon figure but by
all accounts an honest man so I said
he's a professor I sat down with him in
his office and said why are you against
the government he said well I think it's
corrupt and plus I'm in favor of of
same-sex marriage this government is not
but on the trans thing I'm just not sure
and then we went on to talk about other
things at the end of the conversation he
said but you know in the end I can stand
here in my classroom and Budapest and
say whatever I want about the government
and no one will bother me I said Peter
that's really interesting because in the
United States you could say anything you
wanted about anything and the government
won't bother you but if you said what
you did at first that you're in favor of
same-sex marriage but you're just not
sure about trans you would probably have
some students who would report you to to
the uh the administration so they had
been harmed you would have to be in a
Star Chamber defended your job and if
you got fired third you would never work
again so who has more freedom Peter you
here at orban's hungry or your
counterpart in America it just had not
occurred to him because he just didn't
know that that's what it is and it's not
that this is what I was talking about
earlier about
um Orban understanding that power is
exercised not only by the by the state
but also informally by these
institutions I wanted to say quickly too
that I think this fear of suffering is
the basis of this soft therapeutic Brave
New World totalitarianism we have we
have created uh one or two generations
of people who are terrified of suffering
or even of anxiety of relatively mild
suffering when I interviewed people in
Hungary Poland Czech Republic Slovakia
and Russia about what's the most
important lesson that Americans and
others facing soft totalitarianism can
take about how to resist they all said
the most important one was develop a
willingness in the cable ability to
suffer for the truth because they can
hurt you they can fire you they can take
away your Liberty they can do all of
these things but they cannot take away
your integrity this is what sultanitsen
meant by saying live not by lies said if
you stand in the truth and are willing
to suffer for It ultimately the kingdom
of Lies will fall
I don't know how many of you
[Applause]
[Music]
I don't know how many of you saw the
movie it was a Tom Hanks movie that more
people should have seen with Halle Berry
Cloud Atlas did many of you see that it
is an absolutely wonderful sci-fi movie
and the main line the main line of the
movie is I will not be subjected to
criminal abuse and we are all subjecting
ourselves to criminal abuse constantly
when we know that the truth is being
assaulted and we just sit there and do
nothing we are giving it the oxygen to
come for everything so you know the
other part of this is a sort of the
Sci-Fi level and the 1984 level we may
be far worse in some ways this would be
my I'm usually a red pill guy or a uh I
try to give the white pill is like the
red pill is when you wake up to the
world as it is and the white pill is
like a very positive vision of the
future black pill would be the negative
version of future I try to be as much of
a white pill guy as possible the black
pill version of it would be that we are
so deep within the the technological
March towards totalitarian control we're
so deep in it already we don't even know
it and and that you know in essence that
would sort of be like you know the
Skynet has turned on from turbinator
something like that we might be there
already but what kind of person do you
want to be if we're there already do you
want to be someone that that just goes
with it or do you want to see be someone
that stops IT I think probably if you're
here you want to be somebody that stops
IT on that very point in the last I
would say six weeks
um there have been a whole series of
Revelations about institutions like
Hamilton 68 I think it is
um the and the organizations that were
set up
um really in the last five or six years
in the American government to control
and to deter
um expressions of points of view that
were manifestly false damaging or
whatever
um I think for example the first system
real Adventure in that of that kind was
the attempt by institutions of the
government the media
um hike big Tech and so on to argue that
um Trump was a Russian asset this was
something that was said again and again
and again it was believed I believe I
think sincerely believed by people in
positions of authority and influence in
the media it was false from beginning to
end people who resisted this were
vilified they were themselves described
as Russian assets and so on or in or
sometimes naive imitators of Russian
propaganda
um
how you you are yourself active against
that in a very in several ways one of
which was mentioned before your support
for a free enterprise I'm sorry not free
enterprise but a free uh International
media I wonder if you'd want to tell us
how serious
um this Blackpool version of events now
seems the thing is we don't know because
Google like again we are all walking
around with either an iPhone or an
Android device in our pocket right now
is that thing tracking you everywhere
you you go probably is that thing
listening to you at all times probably
how many times have you been talking to
somebody and suddenly Siri starts
transcribing what you're saying into a
text message right like these things
happen you're talking about something
privately with a friend and next thing
you know you get an ad for that thing on
Instagram all we these things are just
happening right you get Phantom buzzes
in your pocket like the Litany of of
weird things and yet no one's putting
the phone down I try not to be on social
media on the weekends and for six years
in a row actually I've done Off the Grid
August where I have no phone no computer
no news no TV for a month it's actually
one of the things that I think in if for
somebody that does Politics on a daily
basis which makes everybody crazy I
think it's one of the things that's kept
me roughly saying well ballpark saying
let's say over these last couple years
um we the black pill version is that
they've sort of got us already and and
there's no way out I just I don't
fundamentally believe that because as
long as look the human Spirit the humans
have been through
you know genocides and humans have been
through world wars and holocausts and
the the endless history of the world
which is unbelievably brutal and
actually if you look at the world right
now uh a couple things notwithstanding
it's fairly peaceful right now we're in
we're in like sort of an information War
but you know we don't have massive
genocides across the world right now
that's not really the default behavior
of humans so things are relatively good
to some extent uh but we just have to
figure out what our relationship will be
with that that digital world because
otherwise we will just be the the
batteries for it you know I um you said
that you've been to Israel you're in
Hungary trying to figure out what you
can take back to America that can help
us with the we Americans struggles we're
dealing with I think that the Israelis
and the hungarians have something we
don't and that is they have a more or
less homogeneous uh ethnicity ethnos
um Hungary is mostly Hungarian Israel is
mostly Jewish you know they share
ethnicity and they share religion we
don't have that in America and it's by
Design you know and that's why you can't
just plug and play Hungary to America
another thing that both countries have
is they're small and they faced for
their entire existence threats to their
very existence
um and so they've had to learn the hard
way limits you know we in the United
States don't even understand what limits
are and so just this week I've read that
there was a report from the government
Accounting Office saying that the U.S
Navy can't deploy ships we're falling
far behind in deploying ships but the
U.S Navy sure can find time to create an
official drag queen digital Ambassador
right you tell that to hungarians they
look at you like oh come on I'm like no
no it's it's real it's happening so I
guess what I would ask you Dave is
um how can you look at the at the
strengths that Israel and Hungary have
but how can we make use of them in
America when we have a very different
history and very different demography
and a very different geographical
situation yeah well first off in my
limited time I'm only here for another
day and a half but this is exactly what
I want to find out more about from the
Hungarian perspective because I really
did find it out from the Israelis
perspective and I think you're right
about that and I also think you know in
their case specifically although
hungary's had external problems their
external problems have been so non-stop
for the entire existence that it
whittled some it whittled a piece of
coal into a diamond in essence but I'll
tell you something that I that I learned
there that was really interesting so
they're in the midst of this uh judicial
reform situation right now and without
getting too far into it basically the
the right believes that the the
Judiciary there has too much legislative
power the left feels that if they give
up that power that ultimately will give
the religious people too much power over
their lives so it really is a battle of
secular versus religious there so I
really went out of my way just like you
talked to that Professor I thought I
want to talk to people on both sides
it's very easy for me to talk to people
on the right but I really want to talk
to people on the left on this and I sat
down with a girl yesterday and we had
coffee in Tel Aviv and she's a full
leftist there and she told me something
that was really amazing she kept well
first of all she didn't tell it to she
didn't say it specifically but it became
obvious as we were talking she kept
talking about how much she loved the
country and she said that you know at
all these protests the the anti-reform
protests uh there are Israeli Flags
everywhere and they're talking about the
history of of the country and the
founding of the country and the
importance of the country and the
historical significance and all of these
things and I thought this now that's
something because this is very different
than the left in America so in America
it's just don't take my word for it take
aoc's word for it take ilhan Omar's word
for it I take Kamala Harris's word for
it take virtually any mainstream
Democrats word for it they will tell you
that the founding of America was a was
flawed it was based in slavery it was
based in racism it was based in the
patriarchy and misogyny and all these
things so when the left is out there
protesting and when they're burning down
cities and BLM and antifa and all these
things they're not out there saying oh
we love America we're just trying to fix
a few of these things they're literally
out there saying we are trying to upend
America I thought that that's a really
interesting difference it sounds to me
like that's also the difference that you
may have here because if that Professor
represents anything of your left that's
the left that you want to strengthen you
might ultimately everyone in this room
might have differences ultimately on
certain policies when it comes uh to to
your left here but if they're not
bananas if they're not out of control
like our left is in America you really
do want to strengthen them if you want
to live in a free Society now it will be
tricky because you will be frustrated
with them all the time right because
you're going to want them to to come to
your side so to speak but
if in America we had a somewhat saying
left right now and we were just arguing
instead of arguing whether America is
fundamentally decent we were arguing
about marginal tax rates and we were
arguing about immigration well that's
what a western Society can do and can
flourish by doing you know that that's
what that's what human communication is
all about
um but I think that's a fundamental
difference and that's also why identity
politics is so dangerous diversity is
not our strength it's a nice piece of
something sometimes but it's not a
strength in and of itself so when
they've gone out of their way to say
America which has taken in all of these
people from everywhere that you must
focus on your identity which was more
important in the place that you fled
than the place that you came to it is
designed it is a bomb in the system
designed to destroy the system and
that's what we have to watch out for I
think uh you know what president prime
minister Orban actually said that big
countries have the luxury to be stupid
while small countries don't have that
because we will you know get destroyed
uh and I think that's what is the case
although I'm not sure whether our left
is actually much better than your left
because they are getting indoctrinated
with all the crazy stuff coming from
America but I had a similar experience
let's say in Estonia they also they know
how to you know uh they had to survive a
very small nation and I think Israel is
a bit the same in this sense I only have
one last question before we open up it
for the for the audience and we kind of
have been beating around the bush uh
around this topic uh I mean you
mentioned for example they don't say gay
Bill and of course uh the progressive
media in America but even here in
Hungary a lot of people think that
actually around the santis was inspired
by what Hungary did which is very
similar so my really question is here is
do you think that Rhonda santis is
taking cues from Orban or somebody who
is working close together with him oh I
actually thought you were going to ask
me something else which I may as well
address I happen to be gay I don't know
if any you know that or care or anything
else I'm married I've been with my
partner for like 15 years we've been
married for I should know this off the
top of my head but about 10 years uh as
long as you don't want to go into
schools and you know dress as a drag
queen and yeah safety kids that is fine
we're okay yeah this is about as crazy
as I dress
um
we have two kids I think the gay thing
happens to be probably the least
interesting thing about me I'm not here
to tell anyone I don't think being gay
is inherently good or bad I think it's
part of the human condition and it's
hard it's part of the uh the Animal
Kingdom right penguins and everything
else
um the fat but you know Jordan talks
about this a lot you know every society
uh should have should sort of have an
ideal model that you'd be striving
towards right so the the ideal model
that that everyone should be striving
towards and this is where certain like
little words could be a little tricky
here so bear with me the ideal model
that we know that works for for
societies obviously as a father and a
mother and children beneath that and
grandparents above that and that's how
you sort of model things out and build a
bottom-up society and that's how
families flourish that we know this but
that doesn't mean it has to be the only
thing and I think what you would want to
do in a free Society is say oh there are
people who are a little bit different
and what are the what are the margin
cases that we can do something with with
when people want to live full
flourishing lives do you want to push
these people all the way to the margins
and and and basically push them out of
society and then God knows what happens
to them there and what they will then
push back on you or do you want to have
a society that can say here here's sort
of the standard right here is the
standard and then there there is room
for other people around that so that's
just to address that which I think is
important to address by the way because
even when I tweeted out that I was
coming here everyone said they're going
to come get you and I was like I don't
know we'll see but so far everyone's
been quite nice so uh
but I've only been with you guys so
um was your question whether Ron
DeSantis is taking
I I don't know anything that that you
don't know let's put it that way but it
seems clear to me even from this
conversation that we're having here that
the the wise Western leaders at the
moment are seeing the same things the
same problems that you guys are seeing
from a Hungarian perspective are the
things that we're seeing from an
American perspective they're almost
exactly the same they're not exactly the
same right like you guys have different
problems with immigration than we have
our immigration Problem by the way in
the last three days or something it's
like it's exploding absolutely we're
doing exactly what Europe did seven
years ago we are just letting everybody
in right now and then it's like we'll
end up where Germany's at right now and
you know hopefully not but uh it seems
like it all could all head in that
direction so I don't know specifically I
don't know that they're talking about
this sort of stuff but I sense it's
fairly obvious if if you are a
functioning decent person there are
obvious problems right now and there are
some solutions that are going to be
tricky and have some pain associated
with them and the media will treat you
horribly but as DeSantis says all the
time the more the media attacks him the
more he knows he's doing the right thing
I suspect that's what's going on here as
well could I just now say that there are
four people on the platform we do
disagree about certain things but it's
there's probably a general commonality
of afterlook and the interest is there
anyone in the audience here today who so
far
um would like to ask a question because
they disagree strongly with something
that seems to be
um I'm sorry oh they disagree with uh
with what you've heard or maybe you
think were that particularly
um Dave Rubin but all of us too are
missing something and we ought to be
aware of is there anybody who would like
to raise
um a hand on that uh yes
it's not as much a disagreement as
something that that Ben that Dave said
that um gave me uh pause and that was he
mentioned sort of the age of our
American politicians now Victor Oberon
is a babe in the woods compared to our
politicians and Rishi sunak is even is
in the womb compared to our politicians
and likewise Emmanuel macron
but what you said was that they're
defending a world that no longer exists
or something but my question is if
indeed that is true then why are they so
easily pulled along into these radical
woke things why why aren't they standing
their ground for the wisdom of former
times
yeah it's a great question I think in
the I can answer it most easily in the
case of Joe Biden where he obviously has
severe cognitive problems we all know it
everyone knows it every speech where he
can't say two words literally two words
in a row without stammering he shakes
hands with the air he walks off in the
wrong direction on Easter Sunday did you
see that last year on Easter Sunday
where they literally sent the Easter
Bunny to go talk to him to move him away
from people in the crowd like it's so
out of control there and so I so he is
no longer the person he's in the body of
Joe Biden but he's not he's not
cognitively there enough which is which
yeah no so some of them are so right
okay so on the case of those people I
think this is where you got to give the
devil his due I think the left has done
something amazing and we all may hate it
we may hate what the left has done to
all of our societies but you have got to
give them credit they have destroyed so
much so quickly and they have taken so
many people and twist them into saying
things that they never would have said
uh you know 5 10 20 years ago if you
took Nancy Pelosi 20 years ago Chuck
Schumer 20 years ago these were not
crazy radical leftists but they decided
to let the inmates run the Asylum I
would say it's a flaw it's a character
flaw probably it's a flaw probably in
belief and it's a flaw that that
politics just kind of breaks people
[Music]
approval and the validation that AOC was
getting on Twitter and thought we'd
better get on board yeah I think in the
case of Nancy Pelosi specifically she
saw these these young girls come in and
the media loved them and there's
probably some uh we could probably get
some biblical story if someone can
figure it out the older woman who wanted
to steal all the power from the younger
women something like that and she wanted
that she wanted to just be part of that
and clearly it didn't end well for her
and and the question is how much of
America will take with it and I think in
the question of the right the normally
Republicans the older Republicans are
terrified of the donor class tariff
terrified of the woke capitalists who
are very much on the left socially and
really only care about keeping their tax
breaks and I think that the older
Republicans just don't know how to
resist business ASA Hutchinson is
governor of Arkansas running for
president now you know he is one of
these people Dave was talking about one
of these normally Republicans who
touched Tucker and Rhonda Santa's for
for being critical of big business I
mean that's that's so of another
generation but they just they don't know
what time it is to use a Claremont
Institute for it yes
next question a gentleman here and then
later
hello Dave so nice to see you here in
Hungary I have a provocative question
for you
uh which is regarding the 2024
presidential elections
is there a possibility that if Trump
wins the Republican nomination we will
see Trump who will shout his things
towards President Biden and people will
vote for Biden because the American
voters will see an angry orange man and
not a reasonable and successful Governor
like the santis
well I think I missed the part in the
middle so is the question if Trump
becomes president
so if Trump gets the Republican
nomination by the Iran C is there a
chance that the same thing will happen
in 2034 during the presidential debate
between Biden and Trump that the people
will see that orange man is bad and we
will vote for by them because oh
absolutely I mean I think there's very
little chance that Trump becomes
president I think there's a numbers
problem there's a reality problem look
Trump got 70 if we're to believe the
last election was legit so that's a
whole other conversation but if we're
basically to believe that then we're to
believe that Joe Biden who basically
didn't campaign got 81 million votes the
most votes in American history and
Donald Trump got the second most votes
in American history 75 million the
question just on a numbers level is
where is a new Trump voter who who is
the person that finally now is like yes
now I get it I'm voting for Trump really
doesn't exist now you could argue that
there'd be a lot less Trump voters
people are tired of of the craziness you
know a lot of the attacks on DeSantis in
the last month they just have not worked
it's partly because it's so patently not
true when Trump goes out there and says
Florida is horrible and all of these
things it's like what or the DeSantis is
a globalist and a rhino it's like this
is not working if if he is a globalist
in a rhino then we're all globalists and
rhinos the guy doing everything we all
are asking for doing it in the more
efficient way than we could have ever
imagined and Trump's going after him so
Trump has a problem in that I don't know
where the new Trump voter is DeSantis
doesn't have that problem DeSantis it's
fairly obvious he can get all the the
guys that you're talking about I can't
wait for DeSantis to be the nominee so I
can look Brett Weinstein in the eye and
Pete bogosian and all of my Democrat
friends and say so are you going to vote
for him yes or no because do you believe
in anything that you have I've tried
this with them many times he's the guy
that can bring over the crossover people
which is why he just won in a huge
Landslide uh I think Trump also has a
problem which is that if he if he
genuinely believes that the election was
stolen which I believe him on his word
that he does well then how does it make
sense you're running again if you
haven't done anything to solve the
problem related to that in terms of
ballot harvesting and everything else so
you have a problem in that you can't get
new voters we just don't know where they
are and if if you believe the thing
you're telling us you believe
they're going to just do it to you again
so I so I to me that's a recipe for for
Biden too if Biden even makes it that
far
good thank you gentleman here
okay so recently in the last few years I
really got this illusioned by the idea
to divide people by the left and the
right ideologies
um I think it's
much more clearer if we look at each
other on exactly what do we think on
certain issues and you are looking for
Solutions you know to have
platforms for free speech to go around
all these uh Shenanigans which the US
government did maybe through Twitter or
the shadow bending all these things
don't you think if the demolishment of
this I am left I'm right thing changes
and we more look at what we really think
and discuss on that basis and we don't
divide ourselves based on left and right
like for example I agree with you on
most of the things we spoke today
migration and this trans ideology
craziness
but still I oppose our government you
know on many things uh but still you
know most of the things we agree on so
why do we have to put ourselves on a
different side of a in a division
it's probably a good question for
everybody up here I I would say briefly
and I used to talk about this a lot sort
of how the labels don't fit anymore and
you know I think instead of left and
right you could basically say
authoritarian or libertarian do you
believe in you know sort of centralized
controller do you believe in individual
autonomy because then then you're not
sort of attaching that to all of the
political you know the policy
prescription so all those things I think
the real reason that we sort of do this
is you need a little shorthand to talk
to groups about basic things right so
it's just somewhat of a way otherwise we
would get lost in every little thing
what do you mean by left also again
having just come from Israel Israel has
a more socialist system right they have
a more left system because they have
socialized Health Care the country
started uh with kibbutz's so these were
communal uh thing you know community
community organizations that nobody
owned that all work for together that
might really work on micro levels but
then they as they became more successful
they grew out of it and became more
capitalist so a lot of the definitions
don't quite work for me it's usually
just shorthand but trust me when I hear
that you have some level of a somewhat
sane left here that's very happy to hear
because of course not everybody is is
that far gone I think the question is
can you strengthen those people enough
to to stop the the worst parts of it I
think that a great Hungarian American
John lukash
said it very well some years ago he said
the future is going to be between people
who believe that they want to live under
the machine and people who want to live
as human beings and I think you can find
people who are on would identify on the
political left or right who could who
are in both or take both sides there
like the the guys we were talking about
Peter pogosi and these others they're on
the in the American left-wing tradition
but Peter when he came here to Budapest
a year ago he had written to me by the
way the a few months earlier we didn't
know each other but he said listen I've
been offered a fellowship at MCC
Matthias corvinus collegium here and I'm
an atheist I'm on the left I don't know
I hear that Hungary is really
conservative I said Peter I think you
should take it because you're coming
from Super woke West Coast University
if you come here you'll find that it's
generally on the right at this school
but the thing that's gonna hit you most
of all is it's possible to have a real
conversation there people there are
interested in what you have to say and
in dialoguing with you nobody's going to
try to cancel you or run you down that's
what we used to have in America and we
don't anymore they still have it in
Hungary well I came here back for a
second time at Danube a month after
Peter had arrived and as Dave said Peter
came up to me and it was like he had
found the promised land he could not
believe how good it was here and to me
that is a testimony to how bad things
have gotten crazy in America and
eventually his woke University drove him
out even though he is a left-wing
atheist because they have this
machine-like view of what of how Society
should be organized it must be shoved
into this ideological form and they
don't want to give people the chance to
be messy and human
can I just come in on that because I
think that this comes up a lot obviously
the political but in a period of
political realignment and that's the the
truth of the matter but I have to say
probably for you gloomy conclusion that
in the end these these different
questions will settle together on a left
right basis and the the reason is this
that there are people who believe in a
Freer economy or a more regulated one
there are people who believe in a in a
more conventional culture and a more
Bohemian one the people who believe
oddly enough in um Bohemian culture tend
themselves to prefer
um not Freer economies but more
regulated ones the people who believe in
free economies tend to prefer a more
solid culture I can I can give you a
good theoretical reason for that freeze
economic societies need morally upright
white people to make sure they go
effectively but when it comes down to it
the choice the the compromise that you
for example feel you have to make at the
moment
um is somewhat uh less serious than you
may think now here's the reason
um that however if you are for example a
believer in a free economy
um and a strong culture culture however
much a conservative party like the Tory
party in England
um imitates the left economically and
becomes more restrictive it's never
going to be as restrictive as the labor
party so you're always going to have a
reason for voting for the right even
when you disapprove of its economic
policies and the same is true for
culture so at the end of the day the
left right thing makes sense over the
long term but not all the time but at
periods when it goes into flux and it
takes time to settle down to the to the
new opinions that have erupted I think
but John can I just push back on that a
little bit that's changing in the United
States now there was a peace and uh
political or maybe a left magazine
saying that Tucker Carlson's economic
populism is breaking the brains of the
left you know and you're seeing now a
merge I mean Gladden papin who's here
with us he's an American conservative
intellectual who is pushing
um for uh what would be considered I
think it's fair to say a more left-wing
version of Economics but he's coming at
it from the right because he believes
correctly that the most important thing
for any government to do is to protect
the family and there's no doubt that
this is
take off my Duff my top hat to you but
the fact of the matter is also
um that the uh your path is made easier
by the fact that the corporations have
gone in a radical moral Direction which
means that a lot of people on on their
on the right are disturbed by the
anti-free speech attitude on the one
hand the support for trans gender
policies of an extreme kind imposed by
the threat of of firing uh dismissal
that these things are a strike most
conservatives who are also free
marketers as outrageous and I think
that's well as I say we're in a period
of realignment I think I think you can
also see that I mean I think the
clearest example from an American
perspective is look at Tucker's position
on the Russia Ukraine war he's the most
sort of isolationist or what you what he
would call America First you know get
out of this war this is going to end up
in World War III that used to be the
position of the Left Right was it the
left was the anti-war party Bernie
Sanders you would think would be leading
the charge against World War III but
he's voting for all of the money that we
are sending over there and all of the
arms and everything else and in it and
you know this is a whole other topic but
in essence we are now bankrolling this
massive war that I would argue we are in
we have no Congressional authorization
for it or anything else but the point is
that this that's a very fundamental flip
on what someone might traditionally say
left and right wait a minute I thought
the left is the peace people and it's
those scary conservatives who want this
panel is divided on that by the way
there's no doubt about that yeah I don't
know I'm not even coming
but it's divided yeah no but but think
about it and now that they've gotten rid
of Tucker and maybe Rupert Murdoch
having had two conversations by phone
with zelinski and March might have had
something to do with that but Tucker's
gone name a single major media figure
the United States who is critical of the
US government policy on the war it's
hard to do
um no they're actually cheering it I
mean again turn on MSNBC that is the
Lefty MSNBC they if all of the
cheerleaders are there yeah and on the
major mainstream figures on the right
most of them are for the War I don't
want to debate the morality of the war
but you would think that in a country as
big as the United States there would be
at least some other voice but it's not
it's a uniparty here in orban's Hungary
you know Orban is against NATO policy in
the war it's easier to find
anti-government commentary in the media
than it is in the United States what
does that tell you probably everything
you need to know and that's again why
our mainstream media it has to be done
with I I am that that is why my biggest
criticism right now of trump is that he
will just keep it going if you want this
craziness to continue with the media
then the guy you want is Trump because
he is the guy who cares about ratings he
cares about who's talking about him and
all of those things he will continually
feed it again I I it this is sort of
like people look at this thing as like a
little nothing but DeSantis starting to
say to these people I will no longer
talk to you you do not do the job you
were set out to do that is the way out
of this and yeah I wish we had more uh
anti-war people in America again
regardless of fully debating all the uh
specifics about the world I just wish we
had less of a una party on war on
economics on any number of things this
is what the real value of Tucker Carlson
was he would have people on his show
that you wouldn't see anywhere else on
the media people from the left he would
have one because he found them interest
second thought they had something
important to say and he's gone now
that's gone well look we have the
infrastructure to free him right I mean
he can I can only say so much but like
there's plenty of operations right now
trying to make sure that Tucker has a
bright future I would say rumble is the
is the number one
if you want Tucker out there saying
whatever he wants to say on an
uncancelable platform and making plenty
of money while he's doing it like that
that to me is the place to go it might
end up that Elon might just sit down
with him and say let's do this thing
together like there there are options
but yes it will not come from the
mainstream media I will say by the way
that's for 40 years conservatives have
been lucky to have had Rupert Murdoch in
charge of of newspapers and media
because without him it would have been
completely dominated by the left
no I'm not I know you're not attacking
him a little boy look but if you if you
want to have
um a media which is diverse the only way
to have it is to have one that is run by
Proprietors because they're plural there
are more than one of them and if you
have that then in the long run you're
gonna you're gonna have every now and
then a media boss who does things you
don't like but if you believe in the
plural ownership of the media then I
think you want to uh you want uh
independent now I have to stop at that
point and say we have time you know with
and beginning to think we may need to
turn the alarm on to get you to leave uh
you know the test worked I thought uh
and and
um so so let me say that we're going to
take one more question and I think we're
going to direct it to our guest uh Dave
Rubin and and then we'll go from there
well now there are 100 questions hands
being raised this gentleman well I leave
it to them
thank you so aggressive people in power
and billionaires use their time and
energy to progress their political
agenda while conservatives don't do it
as much because they're busy going on
with their lives or pursue
non-controversial initiatives so how
could we encourage conservative
billionaires and people in power to use
their resources uh to advance uh a
return to normality or should we even do
that
well it would be nice if more of them
got involved for sure right I think
sometimes you know that you're right I I
think I addressed this a little bit at
the at the beginning of my talk you know
serve again this sort of wide conserved
net you're out there just kind of living
your life and worried about your family
and and what you want on this planet and
all of those things it politics doesn't
become this religious cult-like mission
to to dominate everything you accept
that there are people that are different
than you you you want to agree to
disagree hopefully
um we could probably use more
billionaires in play you know Peter
Thiel obviously was very big in Trump's
first run he's now announced he's not
going to be involved at all in the next
election so that's one going the other
direction I don't think the answer
though is ultimately that because that
if we get bankrolled by enough
billionaires that ultimately that will
solve all of the problems I really do
believe if we build enough of a
decentralized internet if we figure out
enough ways to have Commerce outside of
the system to not have the world
economic Forum push all of their truly
psychotic lunacy on us and if we start
ignoring uh you know a lot of what these
people are pushing on whether it's
climate or trans stuff or some of the
other issues that we've mentioned here
we that's probably the best way to do it
but yeah a couple more billionaires
probably probably wouldn't hurt either
well I would say too that we need to
have fewer billionaires conservative
billionaires throwing their money behind
the Republican party and more of them
putting their money behind cultural
projects building New Media building uh
new colleges like the University of
Austin instead of like who is a hedge
fund guy who just gave 300 million to
Harvard so Harvard was it Mercer
yeah yeah but that's insane you know we
politics is important but it's not going
to solve everything we need to give
money to politics but also uh meaningful
cultural initiatives because the left
owns all the culture and that's as long
as the left owns the culture it's going
to be much harder for us to compete if I
could just say one last thing briefly I
just want to say how absolutely
refreshing this has been you know
America has become deeply unserious it's
really it's really unfortunate and it's
why again why I think DeSantis is kind
of the right way out of this but putting
politics aside just to sit in a room
where people uh audience and colleagues
that are trying to figure a way out of
this thing and clearly something's
working here that really is was the
purpose of my whole mission of doing
this trip and we're going to do many
more like this so I just want to thank
you guys because it's been an absolute
pleasure
well you've already
stolen my Thunder by giving the Applause
before I asked for it so thank you very
much indeed and thank you very much Dave
foreign